Allah He says, whoever does
righteous deeds while he is a
believer. Whoever does
righteous deeds as a believer.
This also means whoever does
righteous deeds and later
becomes a believer. As a
person, when a person accepts
Islam, Whatever righteous deeds
they did prior to Islam is
counted for them. Whatever good
deeds they did is counted for
them. And whatever sins they
may have committed prior to
Islam. They are exonerated
from. As long as they don't
continue them. He says
subhanahu wa ta'ala that which
translates to so whoever does
righteous deeds while he is a
believer No denial will there
be for his effort. Meaning, a
person's effort will not be
denied. A person's effort will
not be, overlooked, will not be
ignored, will not be lost.
and this is an indication that
one of the only things in this
world that is
that is truly guaranteed with
regards to effort is concerned
It is our relationship with
Allah Subhanahu wa ta'ala. that
if an individual puts in an
effort at academics or puts in
an effort in work or puts in an
effort and they may become
wealthy, they may become
prominent, and they may not. a
person may spend his life
trying to discover and not.
However, if a person goes about
worshiping Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala in the proper way, in
the way that the prophet has
instructed with sincerity, they
will reach. They will reach.
They must. This is a guarantee
from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
He says,
and in this as well is the
understanding that a person's
efforts will not be denied,
meaning on the day of
resurrection. When an
individual meets Allah, None of
their good deeds will be
overlooked or missing in their
judgment. And none of their bad
deeds or none of the bad deeds
that they left off will be
missing or overlooked.
Everything will be taken into
account.
He said, Subhanahu wa ta'ala
and indeed we of each
individual's efforts are
recorders. Meaning that the
angels record by the command of
Allah. and being that it is by
the command of Allah and and
the angels are commissioned by
Allah It is correct to say that
Allah is the one who who
records our our deeds. Just
if we were to say
Nope. A city of of
Bridgeview is is building
sidewalks. Does that mean that
every person in the city is out
there building sidewalks, old
ladies, little children? No. it
might not even be a fraction of
the of the population but the
government governing body, as
commissioned this, and so it's
correct to ascribe the action
to the original cause.
Likewise, if we were to say,
a king built a palace. Did the
king himself go down and roll
his sleeves up and build this
palace? Of course not. Not
usually. However, he is the one
who commissioned this and
funded it and whatever.
Therefore, being that it was by
his order, it's correct to say
that to ascribe the action to
him. When Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says and we record what
people do, we're told elsewhere
in the Quran, that's the
angels. Do the recording.
However, these angels have been
commissioned by Allah to do so.
Therefore, it is correct to
ascribe the action to Allah in
this in this manner. He says
and another meaning of this
verse before we continue is
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
recorded the actions in the
preserved tablet
Before the creation. That is
that the prophet was asked,
what is the first thing that
was created? And he said, the
first thing of this universe
that was created as things are,
as we see them. is was the
tablet, the preserved tablet,
and the pen All created the pen
and he said to it, write and
said, what shall I write? He
said, write all that is to be
until the day of resurrection.
And that was 50, 000 years
before the first creation. So,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala wrote
everything that was to
transpire. However, this
doesn't mean that these these
evidences, this verse, others
it, this narration, others
it. This is not an
evidence
against free will. There is a
medium course There is a group
or there is an ideology
excessive free will right?
Where people historically
believe that there is no such
thing as destiny at all and
this is making a reemergence in
popular thought today. that
there's no such thing as
destiny at all. and they've
gone so far as to say that
universe exists many, many,
many other universes exist as
well. They refer to this idea
as the multiverse, right? Say,
innumerable or infinite,
whatever that means, amount of
universes exist and anything
that can happen will happen and
there's no such thing as
destiny. It's all random.
Random chemicals. That is the
more materialistic view and
philosophy This is very very
ancient thought and they would
say that there is a creator.
However, the creator does not
create evil. Rather, people
create evil. as well is from
another branch of of
this ideology. It comes from
the same from the same thought
process The absence of destiny.
is not the belief of the
Muslims. Here is the other side
of the spectrum. The other end,
it is the polar opposite. It
says, There's no such thing as
freewill at all. Destiny is
overarching and we have no free
will, right? This is also
making a reemergence ironically
in modern times. Because part
of belief and modern biology,
and part of belief in and I say
belief, because not everything
that we're told in these books
and so forth is necessarily
something that can be present
with any kind of scientific
model and evolution
specifically that there is no
such thing as free will.
Everything can be reduced down
to chemicals. Right? Everything
can be reduced down to
chemicals. If this chemical
interacts with this chemical,
this will happen. That's it. We
have no free will. This is
well, is rejected and not the
belief of the Muslims. Muslims,
we have a middle ground. There
is destiny and there is free
will. I'm not every Muslim will
understand this dynamic and
honestly speaking, few do.
However, this is what the Quran
teaches us. This is what the
prophet teaches us and if we
don't, each understand how it
fits together, then, this is
more reflective of our human
limits, limitations. We can't
understand everything, right?
a lot of Muslim scholarship has
been devoted to this subject.
There is no creator along with
Allah.
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has written all that is to be
Between these two beliefs,
comes the belief of the Muslim
that we have a free will,
However, that free will is
limited to our, to our options.
You don't have infinite number
of options. We have a finite
number of options and we make
our choices based on the
options that we are presented.
Whether that be the options
that we're aware of or the
options that we are unaware of.
And so, if we were to say, that
the human being is
overpowered by destiny, unable
to make his own choices,
Everything is just Noron's
firing in the brain and they're
firing in the way that
chemicals in our body dictate
then there is no, there is no
difference between human beings
and animals. There is no
difference. Because animals are
AR, driven by instinct, and
they are driven by biology.
Yes. we could somehow look at
all of the chemical balances in
the in an animal and
environmental issues and if we
were to be able to look at all
that knowledge in real time
which we aren't able to not
even close but if we were, we
could, reasonably, We could
reasonably predict what an
animal will do. An animal is
largely reactive.
largely reactive
However, the human being has
free will. And this is why
hellfire and paradise exist in
thee destiny of human beings.
And does not exist and do not
exist with regards to animals.
Animals are not punished for
the way that they are.
and this is the logical
conclusion of theories such as
Darwinian evolution. This is
the logical conclusion. If
there's no difference between
man and animal because all of
us come from animals, and if we
have no free will, then there's
no difference between man and
animals. I don't say this. I
say that's the the next logical
step. However, I don't hold
this belief and I don't force
this. on those who believe in
this evolution, they themselves
say it. Many of us are aware of
the founding father of
Darwinian evolution.
and Darwin wrote his first book
which has a very lengthy title
actually but it's most commonly
known as the origin of species,
right? And he posits in this
book a lot of outlandish things
that he couldn't he couldn't he
couldn't even remotely prove
and this is why there are many
prints of this book with a lot
of addendums done to it. Some
will say, well, that's the
scientific model. No, that's
not the scientific model.
Because what was positive in
that book and books it are
not based on scientific,
unscientific You know,
experimentation. It's just no
way to prove it. Not even in a
super computer today Every
computer program that is used
to try to simulate Darwinian
evolution fails without extreme
amounts of tinkering and adding
laws that do not exist. and
this isn't obviously a talk
about that. However, we just
want to look at the at the
origins of this belief. And why
these two beliefs are making a
remergence in our time. Though
in the origin of species, the
first publication of it.
Darwin said that he could
imagine a bear going down to
the river every day. and his
offspring going down to the
river every day and on and on
for millions of years or
whatever it is he says and he
could imagine that this bear
would eventually turn into a
whale over time. Now, this was
removed from subsequent prints
of this book and rightly so.
Because that is absurd. To the
scientific mind and to the
layperson. How many differences
need to take place for a bear
to become a whale? Imagine, if
you were to say, I want to turn
my car into a submarine. How
many changes would you have to
make to your vehicle to make it
worthy of being a submarine?
And even if you did, somehow
make those changes which by the
end of it, it would not be your
car anymore. And between point
A where it's a vehicle where
roadworthy and point B where it
is C worthy, you have dozens of
years where it is useless. It
can either drive on the road
nor can it be in the water but
let's just ignore that for a
moment. How many how many
changes would you have to make
to a vehicle to turn it into a
submarine? I know that sounds
absurd and it is. However, this
is a very good example and a
much simpler example. Because
the difference between a whale
and a submarine are the
billions, right?
whale
obviously is far more
sophisticated than any
submarine In an astronomical
way, however, even if you were
able to change your car, your
Honda, or your Mercedes, or
whatever it is into a
submarine. How good of a
submarine would it actually
make? Would that submarine
survive very long amongst the
rest of the submarines in the
ocean and it go to war with the
other submarines and So, this
was his first book, right? And
it put forth a belief system
and most of the scientific
community really hooted at this
book. Nobody took it seriously.
This was only taken seriously
in the last 60 or 70 years when
it began to be pushed by a
group of people with a very
particular agenda. Now, the
next book that he wrote was the
descent of man. That's the
second step. That's the next
logical step. If we all came
from animals, then there's no
difference between a human
being and an animal, a human
being is only more evolved than
an animal. Therefore, human
beings are no longer ascended
beings. They're no longer.
They're no longer beings of
higher stature than the animal
kingdom. We are just animals.
Therefore, he wrote the book,
the descent of man. cause
religion the books of Allah
have always propagated that
mankind is superior to the
animal kingdom and if we take
that element away and the
creation of Adam and so forth,
we are left with the human
being, descending back into the
animal kingdom. We will
continue tomorrow inshallah.
Muhammad Ali, he